un tornado azotó el estado de Arkansas
en el sur de Estados Unidos este viernes
varias personas fallecieron y decenas
resultaron heridas otras también
quedaron atrapadas entre los escombros
se registraron daños de vivienda y
negocios como caída de árboles y líneas
eléctricas la gobernadora declaró el
estado de emergencia y desplegó la
guardia nacional
hoy ha sido un día muy duro para el
Estado de Arkansas Pero lo bueno de todo
esto es que Arkansas y los arcanzanos
somos fuertes y resilientes y no importa
lo que nos venga nos levantaremos al día
siguiente y Seguiremos adelante
en el estado de Illinois el techo de un
teatro se derrumbó mientras 260 personas
asistieron a un concierto creando un
caos en la sala
Lo ocurrido es simplemente horrible el
teatro Apolo es uno de los lugares
históricos de la zona y me rompe el
corazón ver el daño que se hizo este
torna do fue provocado por varias
tormentas eléctricas como parte de un
fenómeno extremo de primavera estas
tormentas se produjeron una semana
después de que otro Tornado devastó
parte del Estado de Mississippi matando
a 26 personas y destruyendo al menos 400
viviendas